welcome to the aging phase course
this course has been designed to teach
you all about the early face ecosystem
how to use the data set at model hub as
well as our open source libraries
here is the table of contents as you can
see
it's divided into three sections which
becomes progressively more advanced
at this stage only the first section has
been released
which will teach you the basics of how
to use a transformer model
fine tune it on your own data set and
share the result with the community
we're actively working on the next two
sections
a general timeline wave in mind is to
have section 2 released in the fall
of 2021 and the last section for the end
of 2021
beginning of 2022 was that just
estimates though
don't be married for a bit late the
first chapter requires no technical
knowledge
and is a good introduction to learn what
transferable models can do
and how they could be of use to you or
your company
the next three chapters require a good
knowledge of python
and some basic knowledge of machine
learning and deep learning
if you don't know what a training and
validation set are
or what gradient decent means you should
look at an introductory course
such as the ones published by deep
learning dot ai or fast.ti
it's also best if you have some basics
in one deep learning framework
by torch or tensorflow each part of the
material introduced in this course
has a version in both those frameworks
so we'll be able to pick the one you're
most comfortable with
this is the team that developed this
course i'll now let each of the speakers
introduce themselves briefly
hi my name is matthew and i'm a machine
learning engineer at hugging face
i work on the open source team and i'm
responsible for maintaining particularly
the tensorflow code there
previously i was a machine learning
engineer at parsley who have recently
been acquired by automatic
and i was a postdoctoral researcher
before that at trinity college dublin in
ireland
working on computational genetics and
retinal disease
hi i'm lysander i'm a machine learning
engineer at hugging face i work
specifically on the open source team
i've been at hugging face for a few
years now and i've been working
alongside my team members
on most of the tools that you'll see in
this course
hi i'm silva i'm a research engineer at
talking dockingface
and one of the main maintainers of the
transformers library
previously i worked at fast.ai where i
helped develop the fastai library
as well as the online mooc before that i
was a math and computer science teacher
in france